وقفتنا الاولى الان مع مراسله صباح
العربيه مع الزميله زينب المشاط اول مصنع
في البصره يستخدم الروبوتات كموظفين فيه
وراح نعرف طبعا كل التفاصيل مع زينب اهلا
فيك يا زينب صباح الخير يعني كمان هاي
بلشت الروبوتات تزاحم العراقيين في رزقهم
على ما يبدو صباح الخير شو التفاصيل
طبعا اول مصنع في البصره الجنوبيه العراق
تحديدا في قضاء الزبير جنوبي البصره هذا
المصنع يعمل بنظام الروبوتات
ويعني بلغت تكلفه انشاءه 12 مليون دولار
امريكي وقال رئيس هيئه الاستثمار في
العراق ان هذا المصنع يقدم او يصنع افضل
المواد اللاصقه ومواد البناء السائله
والتي ستنتج تقريبا سنويا 400 الف طن من
هذه المواد ايضا هذا المصنع اختيار ان
يعمل بنظام الروبوت الروبوتات لزياده
الانتاج
وتجنب حدوث اخطاء بشريه نعم البشر البشر
هالمره يعني هذا الشاب اللي افرحنا خبر
انه
عاد الى الحياه بعد ان توقف قلب لمده
عشرين دقيقه شنو التفاصيل سلامه قلبها اول
شيء اي والله الحمد لله على السلامه
سلامه قلوب الجميع
طبعا نعم نحن يعني لازم لازمنا في جنوب
العراق تحديدا في منطقه الفرات الاوسط في
محافظه الديوانيه هناك في مستشفى
الديوانيه التعليمي قام كادر الكادر الطبي
لهذه المستشفى بانقاذ حياه شاب يبلغ من
العمر 24 عاما بعد ان توفي الشاب لمرتين
وخلال 20 دقيقه بالضبط قام الكادر بمجهود
استثنائي كما وصف على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لاعاده الحياه له وباجراء
عمليتين جراحيتين بعد تعرضه لحادث ادى الى
نزيف حاد بالدماغ طبعا نسال الله السلامه
للجميع وكفى الله واياكم شر الحوادث
الشفاء العاجل ان شاء الله وشكرا لكل
الجهود الطاقم الطبي في كل مكان ملائكه
الرحمه وشكرا لك يا زينب
لمتابعتي المزيد
نجوى القصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات